if you are immobile for a
long period of time due to
surgery,
pregnancy or travel,
you may be at increased risk of
deep vein thrombosis, or tgv, a condition
in which
blood clots or blood clots form in the deep veins, usually in the veins of the legs,
in contrast to the arteries.  veins
that move when the
heart beats
veins carry blood with the help of
muscle contractions while moving or
walking
veins also have valves that
prevent backflow of blood and
stagnation in the arms and legs when you do not
move for a long time,
blood flow through the veins slows down
clotting factors in the blood  can
cause blood to
clot and form a blood
clot or clot when not moving this condition
is called deep vein thrombosis or
tgv the most common symptoms of tgv
are leg swelling or swelling of a vein in the
leg pain and tenderness in
the area increased skin temperature
redness or blanching  skin
in some cases tgv a blood clot
can break away from a deep vein and
enter the general circulation a
clot from the deep veins of the legs enter the
abdominal veins
and then into the heart from where it reaches the
pulmonary artery blows,
blocking blood flow to the lungs
this condition called
pulmonary embolism is a very serious
disease that  can lead to
chronic damage to part of the lung
if the clot is large or if there are
many clots pulmonary embolism
can lead to death of the patient if
you have symptoms of the rear and
tell your doctor
and nurse immediately these symptoms
include shortness of breath sudden sharp pain
in the chest dizziness
palpitations and irregular heartbeat during exercise
hemoptysis
to prevent deep vein thrombosis and
pulmonary embolism
your doctor may tell you to
get up and walk regularly to help
prevent congestion in your legs
wear compression socks take
anti-clotting drugs